all right
we're live now for the march 2022 ama
and i'm starting just a little bit early
because i logged in and saw that there's
already a lot of
questions and comments so let's uh
get started
um carl bond have you ever read any
jacques barzun if so thoughts if not
ever feel the need to follow up like et
cetera et cetera yeah i read barzoo and
i started reading him back in graduate
school so we're talking over 20 years
ago
and i found him insightful
from time to time but i never
like
i you could say i never like bought into
his his overall
project what i took it to be
um i mean sometimes this is the way it
often is with cultural critics you know
you can agree with them on some things
and be like wow you totally missed the
point of this thing over here
um you know you could say that he's sort
of like neil postman or who else
comes to mind as somebody who has read
very widely lionel trilling
you know they they don't produce a lot
of original stuff of their own but they
have a lot to say about
what's out there
um so yeah barzun you know not bad uh
kind of hit and miss um
johann says how would maurice blondel
respond to jacques derrida's works and
vice versa
well i discussed that quite a bit in my
dissertation and
also in one of my first publications a
book chapter specifically about blondel
and derrida in continental philosophy of
religion
he would probably say wow jacques you've
rediscovered a lot of insights that i've
already expressed in my works about
reading a work against itself you know
what blondel called the method of
charity and also the method of imminence
and implication is uh similar to what
what darida is doing in terms of
deconstruction
um when it's done best which just goes
to show you that dairy does
deconstruction was not something
radically new um i doubt dairy now would
have an awful lot to say
in in response to blondel
um
[Music]
you know it's it's a question i mean
you'd probably like
interestingly and selectively
misunderstand what he's saying right
um but i i don't i don't picture derrida
um be it's probably it probably wouldn't
be a very interesting um back and forth
discussion so
all right uh zach what draws you to
christianity as opposed to other
religions been getting into christianity
recently and i'm wondering about your
take well my take is that things aren't
even remotely like that it's not like we
kind of like well i i think i like this
religion better than this religion
no you you study you practice you engage
you you know um
it it's impossible to
like be interested in christianity
as opposed to buddhism
you know or
pick whatever else you want unless
you're at this extraordinarily high
level of generality where nobody
actually
lives or does anything
you know
i read i read plenty of of stuff outside
of christian authors when it comes to
religion and there's things that i find
interesting or attractive about them and
there's many christians
who you know uh are billed as such that
i consider to be you know completely
noxious and why the hell would i want to
engage with them at all so things are
not quite so simple as like you pick one
thing or pick another i'm i'm attracted
to
um thinking things through in terms of
you know these great questions and
in the west christianity
is certainly one of uh the main you
could say communities that thinks
through them but not exclusively
so
in a way this is sort of a what we call
a category mistake in philosophy right
christianity it's not really a category
as such at this level
uh joseph uh was hysterol the
philosopher that started the use of the
word thematic and thematicity and
phenomenology
what does it mean for a phenomenon to
become thematic i i don't know i mean
phenomenology doesn't have just one
origin at the time of his role there's
also you know maurice blondell and
bergson both of whom are clearly doing
something like phenomenology not calling
it phenomenology mock shaler is just as
important early on
as husserl is
um and you know of course then we get
heidegger coming in
so and and what is what is uh
what does it mean for a phenomenon to
become thematic
look at which phenomenologist you want
to focus on i mean the the simplest most
general way of saying is we're paying
attention to it and focusing on it
thematize i think is often used as sort
of a substitute you know jargony
sounding word for we're now going to
systematically look at something um so i
mean is hustle the person who originates
it i don't know
you know um i i i it doesn't strike me
as something that uh i mean there there
could be a good article for you know
philosophy and phenomenological research
or the journal of the history of
philosophy in there but
tracing out those those
origins of terms is is not something
that i devote a lot of time to
jd sword nice to see you here
seems as though the politics of the cold
war the latest 80s trend to make a
comeback
with the invasion of ukraine do you
think there's something to the idea that
history repeats itself no not really
i think i don't think history repeats
itself i think that isolated dynamics
within history often bear
a lot of resemblance to each other but
this actually doesn't look like the cold
war to me
because i mean we have an entire
political party here in the united
states that's basically beholden to our
cold war
enemy the soviet union now russia right
the republicans uh you know for a long
time can't say enough about how
wonderful putin and russia is and
you didn't really see the democrats
doing that if the things flip-flopped
during the cold war as a matter of fact
that was the thing where republicans and
democrats
more or less came together back in the
um you know say
truman through
um
reagan slash bush one era
and you know
contemporary russia it's interesting
there's been a lot of like discussion
recently about well what if what if
russia lines up with china and with
india against us you know
and
the answer would be well if russia wants
to be a penny anti
second rate nation you know basically
controlled by the chinese i guess that
you know cool for them
our big geopolitical rival right now is
obviously china not not russia
russia is a unfortunately for its
citizens
um kind of a bankrupt country you know
negative population growth high rates of
alcoholism and and you know suicide uh
clearly
you know
civil societies and a real mess there
so
you know it's it's not a great place to
to be and it's not offering
a model i mean here's the thing when we
talk about like the cold war we had two
main models
that were being offered the you know
ostensibly democratic capitalist west
and the
uh socialist republics primarily those
uh
you know in the ussr uh and then the
warsaw pact countries and then we had
you know like a
possibility of a third force you know
charles de gaulle tried to organize that
idea
what we call the third world meant the
non-aligned world
um i don't think that we're we're in
that sort of situation now at this point
so
i think we're in a different kind of uh
situation
all right um azad asked do you think
prince mushkin and ali osha
were dostoevsky's final solution
um what was he promoting i don't think
there was a final solution in
dostoevsky's works i actually
um am convinced by
mikhail bakhtin's reading of dostoyevsky
that that views dostoyevsky like um
shakespeare as providing us with
polyphonic novels right where there is a
lot of
ethical projects being worked out but
dostoevsky himself while he may be
definitely
against certain things
is not
is not to be identified with any one
single
character and their
perspectives um so i don't think that
dostoevsky has a
final solution he has a very interesting
set of
problems and he doesn't just leave them
as problems he lets the characters kind
of work them out both in action and
thought and discourse in relationship
with each other
so that's a good question um
yeah i mean if we were gonna have to
pick between the two of them i don't
think that
that mush can
you know the protagonist of the idiot um
would would be it alyosha would probably
be
you know
a better candidate but i don't think
that that's what dostoevsky is really up
to so
[Music]
oh mark uh weighs in just wanted to say
i placed my order for some banjo
metaphysics merch today
excited for the delivery here's wishing
the news uh store all the best
your favorite item you like making so
mark is referencing you know people have
been asking for a long time for merch
and a youtube store and so i i did the
work and it turned out to be an
extraordinarily
uh large amount of work much more than i
thought it would be and i can tell the
story about that some other time
all the ins and outs of that but i do
have three designs that are available on
things like t-shirts and mugs and
in one case a fanny pack and
what else uh wall hangings and stuff
like that and
so the banjo metaphysics that design is
taken from that class that i did back at
marist college
over 10 years ago in an intro to
philosophy class i brought my banjo in
to talk about aristotle's four causes
right
and uh you know so there's video
recording of me at the chalkboard and
i'm holding it and i play it at one
point
um so i took uh i took some screenshots
from that
and uh uh put them in black
in red and yellow and blue and green
into a nice square and i'd say that's
actually my favorite design i thought
people might like the idea of i study
with sandler being able to identify with
the channel so i created something like
that but obviously i'm not going to wear
something like that because i'm the
saddler i don't study with myself
and then i created something for the
half hour hegel series just using the
the different colors of the
video thumbnails and
i'll probably get myself i can get
samples so i need to get myself some
some of those and you know start wearing
them around to the gym they say if you
if you you know do an ama when people
are uh seeing you in a shirt it's more
likely to sell and stuff like that so
but i'm doing it i'm doing this whole
merch thing in an experimental and
quirky way
i'm not following the best practices and
rules because i kind of just want to do
it my way you know i want to create some
designs and see if people like them and
respond to them and if they do i'll
create some more if they don't
you know
nothing really lost
it's not like i had to buy a whole bunch
of t-shirts and then ship them out or
something so so we'll see what happens
um but yeah i'm glad you got one mark
that's that's cool i mean people are
going to be looking at it and be like
what the hell is that
[Music]
all right galen i'm not sure if adam
smith is in your repertoire but do you
agree we can't properly understand
wealth of nations unless we read it in
light of what he says in theory of moral
sentiments um yeah i mean i've been i've
been teaching uh smith for quite a long
time mostly in business ethics classes
and i would i would actually say two
things
the first thing is yeah if you if you
want to understand wealth of nations
properly
read the other big book theory of moral
sentiments that's important but i would
say that the biggest problem is that
most people reading
the uh wealth of nations read it
inattentively because they come in
already primed to like find capitalism
there in a defense of it and if you read
the book carefully even if you put aside
the theory of moral sentiments
um
smith is closer to marx than he is to
contemporary capitalists you know
because
he's clear about um you know the dangers
of monopolies for example and you know
cartels and
uh the the uh uh sort of gains that are
that are made within the workshop don't
necessarily translate into industrial
capitalism the way that people think and
he's very very clear about the need
to avoid the corrosive moral effects
that
capitalist
actions and society and mindsets can
lead to i mean you know smith thinks
that people need to actually be virtuous
not just call themselves virtuous and i
mean he he would he would be pretty
condemnatory and and critical of a lot
of what goes on under his name in the
present so i think i think there's a lot
of readers who um
they come you know they'll get it
through liberty fund or something like
that
and they're already you know primed to
read smith as providing the arguments
for capitalism
when it's a much more nuanced book than
that you know so
quite important
um
ozzy mondias how are you hope you're
doing well i was wondering if you think
there's any contemporary christian
philosophy you find compelling
any particular writers who come to mind
um you know contemporary christian
thinkers uh that are still doing
philosophy yeah lester mcintyre a pretty
famous convert
um
i mean he and i don't see eye to eye
necessarily on the problem of christian
philosophy which i got to you know
present to him and talk with him about
um back when i was doing that that
seminar um
but yeah i mean he'd be one i mean who
else i mean i know some contemporary
philosophers who are christians but i
don't know that they bill themselves as
christian philosophers
um
a lot of us are working in in the
history of philosophy and and we're not
you know we're not just working
exclusively on like i'm an augustinian
or something like that
but you know sort of contextualizing
uh ancient philosophy and christianity
or thinking about early modern stuff you
know and how it may be applicable
um
i mean i've met jean-luc mario i'm not
i'm not a huge fan of his stuff um quite
frankly i i think that there's some
interesting insights but
i think that he throws out way too much
baby with the bathwater because he buys
into this you know heidi gary and slash
deridian
uh you know critique of metaphysics
thing
that is
kind of unnecessary and misleading
um
i don't know about i mean i i don't move
too much in
uh
christian philosophical circles i mean
i'm not moving in any circles right now
other than virtually
so i don't really know
it's a good question
um
victor i enjoyed reading your classical
medi metal class i was wondering do you
enjoy alternative metal like deftones
tool
or perhaps alice and chains as well
yeah i mean in the 1990s i mean you can
call it alternative metal
we just called it metal back then
you know
there were a lot of interesting things
going on
in the 90s i was more listening to bands
like tool and
alison chains um than i was to the
classic metal stuff
by the mid-90s right early 90s i was
still doing a lot of that
and i also got you know pretty heavily
into grunge i mean i got myself a bass
and i was i was playing never got into a
band that actually went anywhere but we
were playing a lot of you know stone
temple pilots and pearl jam and nirvana
and stuff like that
um
as well as you know continuing to play
sabbath and motorhead and
iron maiden
and so yeah i got into that i also got
into prong you know and these weird time
signatures
um and i still i still do listen to
some of that you know early mid late 90s
stuff
which i consider to be
quite good um
i didn't go into too many other
directions that metal was going at the
time like i didn't get into the
genres like death or black or
folk or things like that i mean another
another band that really is alternative
metal um
that was a little bit earlier faith no
more they they were quite interesting
and yeah we would get into that um
you know we wanted to stay i guess you
could say that we wanted to stay on top
of like heavy music that we could relate
to
so you know bands like um
the breeders for example or pj harvey
um
there's a heaviness to their their music
right that's that's continuing on you
could say the project of
of metal in a very broad sense
and you know
if i had the opportunity to go see them
at shows i probably would
um so yeah good good question there
philip asks how do you understand
aleister mcintyre's opposition to kant's
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals
is he criticizing its limitations to
support a collective society socially
agreed upon morality
um
i mean mcintyre is not criticizing
kant's groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals he's criticizing kant's project
moral project overall
which includes the for the second
critique and the actual metaphysics of
morals and the
religion within the limits of reason
alone and you know a number of other
works as well which would include some
of the occasional essays like perpetual
peace or what is enlightenment he's not
he's not taking the groundwork as like
the single uh best example example of
kant's um
work throughout mcintyre's work and
after virtue
you see him talking about
consciousness and kant but he's also you
know broadening he takes kant as sort of
like the prototypical deontologist
concerned with principles and rules and
you know all all of that sort of
approach and and mcintyre is never
somebody to throw things out right
he's he's uh
clearly
a dialectical aristotelian philosopher
even before after virtue uh when he's
still in in his sort of marxist phase
right
um no big surprise marx is very
aristotelian actually
and he he wants to say okay what can we
actually get from this and then where
are the inadequacies of this sort of
approach
and it's it's not just about having a
collective socially agreed upon morality
i mean i i don't think that's really
what macintyre's project is
um you know if you read the
after virtue and then you read the the
rest of the quadrilogy attentively there
never ever ever was a collectively
socially agreed upon morality there's
always been rival
moralities and they've always been sort
of like over a
a perpetual you know we could say
churning abyss of purely transactional
morality
uh that's that's been going on so i i
don't think that
um
i don't think you want to look at it in
quite so schematic a way what mcintyre
is doing
but you know i mean his basic idea on on
kant is that
kant can't provide us with what we
actually
need although there are plenty of people
who
endorse a sort of
you know low-level conscience approach
to things and i think he's you know
that that take is basically correct um
he also thinks that you know sooner or
later you're going to have some people
who are basically utilitarians as well
in the mix and some it changes the name
from a motivist to expressivist
you've used a lot of existentialist
philosophies fitting in there there's
going to be some like that
and there's going to there's also going
to be some fake aristotelians in the mix
as well that you have to deal with right
so
uh
profound you mentioned that you like
aleister mcintyre you don't agree with
everything he says i mean mcintyre
himself would probably not like a
mcintyrene who um
agrees with everything he says just by
the the very nature of mcintyre's
philosophy and the way he understands
how to do
uh moral theory
um is there anything in particular you
disagree with yeah i've talked about
this in a number of amas because this
question has been asked a number of
times
he gets you know some some of his
history of philosophy wrong i've
actually like i mean you can find the
video out there i presented a a paper at
the uh
international society of mcintyre and
inquiry years back where i said mcintyre
got anselm wrong and here's here's what
he could have if he'd if he looked at
these texts of anselm here's what he
could have seen and this would have
actually have strengthened his position
but instead he
he basically ignored or uh dismissed
anselm
in favor of uh you know a more thomastic
uh
oriented history
we know we got the stoics wrong
anthony long wrote a
amazing piece
years and years and years back
basically saying
listen alistair you know
this this stuff that you're saying about
the stoics you got them wrong and they
would have been a very similar rival
tradition to what you're you know
pitching as this aristotelian tradition
it's got all the moving parts that
you're looking for
um and i would actually go so far as to
say that neoplatonism offers us a
similar thing as well
um he got kierkegaard
wrong in certain respects to the degree
that kierkegaard scholars actually
authored a collected volume
uh of essays criticizing mcintyre to
which mcintyre himself responded right
so there's a lot of like getting things
wrong in terms of history
that's probably
enough at this point i will actually say
one other thing so mcintyre back in the
bush uh
bush versus kerry campaign
aleister mcintyre and paul griffiths
both authored pieces basically saying
if you're a faithful catholic you can't
vote for the republicans or the
democrats and there was a lot of like
well you can't vote for the democrats
because of abortion and then griffiths
and mcintyre were like well you can't
vote for these these republicans either
remember this is like before the tea
party before the trump craziness before
the slide into you know fascism and
craziness and all that sort of stuff
this is back in 2004
i
didn't find that convincing because a
principled non-vote
just goes into the same hopper as all
the other non-votes
a sort of no no you know register and i
don't think that's particularly helpful
so that that was another thing as well
all right a lot of mcintyre stuff
interestingly here i'm not quite sure
what that is about but uh
let's see here
cinder you mentioned somewhere that
mcintyre in some ways gets foucault
wrong
in what ways do you think he did and
what could he have done better any okay
so i mean anybody can do better by
paying closer attention and devoting
more time and and thought to what
they're responding to i mean i think
that um
you know foucault
is um
[Music]
he is doing a genealogical project i
don't see mcintyre taking account of the
shift
after the genealogical project to what's
going on in the history of sexuality
um
and you know
foucault is a fairly
careful assembler let's say of
historical evidence i mean he's clearly
telling a a story that sometimes you can
say yeah that's probably true in other
other cases you could be like
oh i'm not really sure about that
especially if you know the material that
foucault is working with but you can say
that about just about any any
interpretation of history as a matter of
fact anybody who thinks that history is
easy and straightforward um they're not
working with history right they're
working with something else instead
i mean
one of the things i should say
mcintyre
when he arranges these
three rival versions of moral inquiry
and that's the name of one of the books
the third book in the quadrilogy right
um
so you got enlightenment or encyclopedia
you've got genealogy right and then
you've got tradition constituted
rationality
tradition constituted rationality is
only worth a crap when it actually
engages with these other two
things right and doesn't just dismiss
them it's not doing the benedict option
ala
rodriguez crappy uh
misconstrual of it that mcintyre by the
way has had a lot to say about just
google mcintyre benedict option and
you'll see him ripping drayer apart on
this but a lot of people like like to
use mcintyre as kind of a call
for that isolative thing
whereas mcintyre isn't for that at all
you know
um
so i would say you know
in so far as genealogy can sometimes be
written off that's i'm not going to say
mcintyre is making that mistake i'll say
readers of mcintyre making that that
mistake
uh retro gamer thanks for providing the
hegel video index helpful in many ways
to study and return to enjoy the text
yeah so i last night on medium i i took
the stuff that i had previously on the
half hour hegel blog
where i i had like pages and pages of
links to the videos organized according
to
the you know table of contents
of the phenomenology which i just happen
to have here so like you know you can
see there's some real structure right
and the reason why i wanted to create a
list that reflected that structure
is because um
youtube you know you can create a
playlist right and there is a there is
still a half hour hegel playlist but the
trouble is it's not i mean it's
organized sequentially so each video
follows the next
but that doesn't give you like okay i
want to go to you know this particular
section
of
spirit uh let's pick something at random
all right i need to look at culture and
its realm of actuality okay so that is
self-alienated spirit culture which is
the b section
uh and this is in um you know section
one of that
well you can go to the curated list and
you can scroll down you can find it
right away right so
i think that's that's that's quite
helpful for people
especially if they're going to use it as
a study aid
just going to certain sections of the
phenomenology
i i don't understand why youtube doesn't
do better playlists i mean this is a i
hadn't really thought about this at the
time but your comment makes me think
about that
what would it cost them to to allow us
to do
you know a little bit of nesting or
organization in it
i'm sure it couldn't be that difficult
to
to code but
they don't seem to have any interest in
that and and you know it's not like
anybody out there in youtube in the
company is really listening to any of us
so
um unless we get like a million people
to sign a petition or something like
that so all right
uh
marcos asks is this live
i mean it's a live stream so yeah it's
it's kind of trivially true right
uh lapse continuum is it possible that
truth itself not just knowledge might be
partial or come in degrees absolutely i
mean
that's that's sort of uh uh
you're asking sort of is is it possible
for water to be wet yeah
i mean is it possible for us to drink
water sure i mean
who's who's out there preaching that
truth is is either like totally true or
totally false you know
um
or doesn't come in degrees you know does
the question make sense yeah it makes
sense but it's one of those things where
i think unless somebody's got an
extraordinarily weird view on truth
which of course you can ask well how
true is this and then you're
doing degrees with them right
um it seems it seems kind of like a
non-starter to me
i mean i will say this people
in rhetorical situations and not just
rhetorical but heuristic rhetorical
situations where they're trying to
you know disprove the other person and
make their side the only winner
they will often say stuff like well if
you lied once you're totally a liar and
we don't trust anything you say
but
that's such [ __ ] you know that that
that can't possibly work for us as as
human beings right
um
muhammad terence i am human i think
nothing human is alien to me how do you
see invasion of ukraine and other
maddening stuff do you see a light at
the end of the tunnel for humanity why
are we not
i mean when in history has there not
been maddening stuff like this i mean
just think about putin himself if you're
maddened by the invasion of ukraine why
not be maddened about the uh
chechen war or the uh russian
you know uh support of the assad regime
and it's
horrible horrible things that it's been
doing to its own people for
years and years or i mean this is this
is not something the ukraine thing is
not something
radically new right um i mean
i you know i i'm gonna say something and
this this may bother some people i
remember back in
graduate school it was it was kind of a
big thing to talk about the holocaust
all the time right
and um you know clearly the holocaust
happened and it happened
to a lot of people but
jews were certainly at the center of it
and clearly ideologically that was that
was a main point of the holocaust and i
remember my mentor garth gilland in
class one day
saying um
the holocaust is uniquely terrible and
all that sort of stuff and i was like
get you know you're full of crap
i mean the rwandan genocide which also
is driven by some of these same fascist
ideology stuff if you actually look into
what was going on you know the
propaganda that was being used by the
hutus
against the tutsis some of it derives
from you know colonial uh
realms and all that there's like a whole
argument to be put there i was like
you know it's not as
big but
you know somebody killed in that
genocide is just as dead as somebody in
another genocide aren't they and
do you think it matters that it was
oriented by nazism or by this this
ideology you know and i think you can
say the same thing for um what happens
in in you know criminality
and in
wars and
violence and bad policing and all sorts
of things um there's lots and lots of
evil in the world sure you know uh
nobody's really
debating that it's just that we're now
seeing uh some of it being thrown in our
face a little bit more
i don't have a problem living in a
world in which things are messed up
because i don't expect the world to be
radically different than it is and i
have hope for humanity all the time
because
the world isn't just the crappy parts
right and even the crappy parts we can
say well look at the heroic actions of
of you know these ukrainians or we can
say wow you know extending mercy to
a soldier who doesn't want to be there
and surrenders and instead of like
kicking his teeth in and saying you know
die russian scum giving him some food
that's you know an act of uh
uh hospitality right there that's that's
also equally humanity right so i this is
for me not not that big of an
issue and it doesn't mean that we don't
get upset about things you know
or um oppose injustice but we it doesn't
have to [ __ ] us and turn us into
despairs you could say
all right uh gavin says i'm a beginner
in this stuff and devour your fantastic
vids on plato going through them all for
my next steps any thoughts on doing your
home study aristotle course versus world
worldviews course so he's mentioning two
things that i have in my reason i o
academy
um i i have a worldviews and values
course that i taught at marist college
and developed a bunch of resources for
and so i you know when i quit teaching
for marist i was like well maybe people
would want to
uh
go through this and and see what was in
an academic course so i put it there in
in my teachable academy and
uh charged a you know pretty low uh uh
price for it i like to keep things as
affordable as possible so that more
people can have access to them
um and then the aristotle course is
aristotle's nick and mccain ethics and
the answer is you can do either i mean
there's
there's i don't have advice about which
one you ought to do that's that's up to
you
um you should look at what they're
covering and you know the world views
and values course
remembering off the top of my head
covered some parts of plato's republic
some epictetus some boethiah well the
whole of the the
the uh
um consolation of philosophy
um
rene descartes discourse
on method thomas hobbs bits of the
leviathan
mary wollstonecraft parts of vindication
of the rights of women jean-jacques
rousseau's
discourse on the origins of inequality
mark's uh alienated labor and the
communist manifesto and then martin
luther king's letter from a birmingham
jail and i have a dream and i don't
think i'm leaving anybody
out in that so if that's your game you
know if that sounds interesting to you
then you can you can take that right
um if you
would rather like continue things you
know more chronologically than
aristotle's nick and mccain ethics is
certainly a great text to look at and
i've got videos covering the entirety of
it so you know
either is you know either's fine i would
say
um
air is it ericas
hello how do you view cot nature
dichotomy and contemporary philosophical
themes especially between rawls and
adversaries
do you see it as a necessary dichotomy i
don't even see it as a dichotomy because
a dichotomy would be like everything
falls on one side or the other
so
kant has uh some ideas
it takes a bit of work to apply them to
political philosophy right even though
he does have some political philosophy
but you know you got to do some
stretching to get there
um
nietzsche you know what is his political
philosophy ask 20 nietzscheans get 20 22
answers right so i don't i don't know
that
that's going to really
um
work you know because you don't even
have a coherent thing that's the
nietzschean
uh response and how these are connected
with rawls and his adversaries i i don't
i don't see connections between all
these sorts of things i mean you can say
that rawls is
kind of conscient in some respects right
but that's about as good as i think you
can get
richard santos what's a good path to
follow in order to build a strong
philosophy background i'd like to build
on a sound foundation that will give me
the ability to better access different
thoughts
well
reading philosophy studying uh
philosophers that we acknowledge as
clearly having something you know
interesting and useful to say
i mean you don't have to study everybody
because you can't
which is a big problem in itself
uh you probably couldn't even do so back
in hegel's time but you definitely can't
do so today
so you know i would say at least at the
beginning stick with people that
people who you respect are like yeah you
got to read some plato you got to read
some aristotle you should probably read
some
of the stoics here's some seneca you
know don't just read marcus aurelius the
way that the tech bros and uh
you know kind of stoic posers do
actually read more hardcore stoic texts
um
can't read much epicurus because we
don't have much epicurus unfortunately
but you can read lucretius's on the the
nature of things edited by cicero we we
think most likely by the way and you can
go through the progression you can be
like well you know i heard bad things
about descartes but i know he's
important and as you're approaching each
of these you should think what can i get
from them i don't need to become a
cartesian to read descartes
and the the end product of reading
descartes doesn't have to be me becoming
a cartesian but i should i should know
what he has to say so that when somebody
comes along and criticizes cartesian
dualism i can say well this person knows
what they're talking about or they've
just you know read a few encyclopedia
entries on it
they don't know what they're talking
about and here's here's what my response
would be
so that that you know
i'd say that can be helpful i've got
some uh not not enough of them of course
but i've got some videos on
self-directed study that are in a
playlist that might be helpful for you
i need to start doing more of those and
also a few other things about
self-directed study
all right your average french
something something uh
recently an e coli bacteria was made
with human-made dna let's say we exactly
copy-pasted the genome of a fertilized
human egg and provided enough nutrients
did we create the same human or not
merely copied nature's framework will
we become gods
is there an ethical or metaphysical
implication of molecular biology
breaking the sacred halo of birth death
and
birth and death
i mean this sort of thing's been going
on for a while right
and uh
will we become gods it depends on what
you mean by becoming gods i mean that's
a pretty vague notion so you want to
you want to be clear about what you mean
by that um
[Music]
i mean we're doing all sorts of stuff
with manipulating dna
and it raises some interesting questions
the did we create the same human
um
i don't think that that cloning
is really
just simply replicating a human we can
talk about replicating you know the dna
but
am i just my dna um
a similar problem on the other end about
like consciousness you upload my
consciousness a la sci-fi
into a computer and then you put it into
a new meat machine is it the same guy
who knows you know all of these are
really more pragmatic uh questions where
you got to say well depends on what you
mean by same right and this is where
philosophy i think can be very helpful
because philosophers are good at making
distinctions and making it clear
why distinctions um
you know how they apply right
all right uh
abhishek you have no video made of made
of indian thinkers yeah no [ __ ]
you're not pointing out something to me
i don't know i've talked about this many
many many many times usually it's
phrased more like why don't you have
videos on indian thinkers
because i'm not a specialist in indian
philosophy and i don't read sanskrit or
hindi or
pali for that matter
and i tend to stick to the stuff that
i'm good at and leave the vast world of
the internet to the the millions of
other people who could do better videos
than me on that material you know why
should i do stuff on indian philosophy
or islamic philosophy or chinese
philosophy when there's better people to
do it and there's plenty of people out
there already doing it you know
people bring this up as if it's like you
know
i i'm supposed to do everything
i'm not even doing everything in western
philosophy
so
why would i you know turn to something
that's got a just as long of a backstory
and a massive massive number of texts
and not do the work that i'm doing over
here to do a little bit of dabbling and
dilettantism over over here it seems
kind of a
bad use of my time and it's probably
going to produce videos that are not as
good as what other people could produce
right
um
all right huey what was the first
philosophy book that had a tremendous
impact on your perspective
while you're on it what's your morning
routine i mean totally unconnected
my morning routine is wake up have some
coffee and then see what the day holds
you know i don't i don't do a lot of
routines and stuff like that i'm not i'm
not there's there's a lot of people that
are into that sort of stuff i gotta
begin my day with my affirmations
ah i did that sort of stuff i'm not that
works for some people
i i'm you know
i'm not into that so
um first philosophy book that had a
tremendous impact on my perspective
um
that's a good question i mean i read
camus
myth of sisyphus that's the first
philosophy book i had
but i didn't understand most of what i
was reading that was that was back in
high school
um
you know and i read i kind of read
passages and selections but reading like
a whole
philosophy book
um
[Music]
so
you know this is going to sound weird i
think to a lot of people
um
but it probably was
starts being in nothingness
which i started reading
in a serious way my my sophomore year
of college reading on my own you know
um
and you know i i again didn't understand
everything i was reading
maybe 50 of what i was reading
but it did have a big impact on me i
went through a sartre and phase you know
and i i got really into existentialism
so i would say that that's probably it
uh message
who do you consider first and second
rate thinkers i mean that that could be
like an entire
long video um you know plato's a
first-rate thinker seneca is a
first-rate thinker cicero's a first-rate
thinker
um
as a matter of fact there's quite a few
first-rate thinkers in in the ancient
world
i would say you know
we jump to the to the present mcintyre
is a first-rate thinker julianas is a
first-rate thinker
um chris gill anthony long these sort of
people
um
you know a lot of a lot of the second
rate thinkers or maybe even like third
or fourth fifth ranker
rank thinkers are the people that we
look at as gurus today you know the
jordan petersons and sam harris's and
you know nassim tellebs and people like
that that have big followings but
you know nobody's going to be reading
their crap 100 years from now
they're just going to be footnotes in in
other people's books sort of like
herbert spencer right who reads herbert
spencer today not too many not too many
people but he was a big deal back in his
day
um
i don't know it often depends on like
well how how good is the engagement of
other people's ideas and then what about
the development of your own ideas you
know
um
ridicule thoughts on i'm not even going
to try to pronounce his name and flo
states his work has apparently
influenced julianis's conception of
virtuous activity i don't know i i
haven't seen that i'd have to check it
out i think that the the flow state
stuff is
um
you know
it could be interesting people make way
way way too much of this this sort of
thing and i haven't read his work so i
don't know how rigorous it is or whether
he's you know
making a lot of you know silly easy easy
to make mistakes or stuff like that so
um huey have you read infinite just
before what do you think about david
foster wallace it's author
i'm not interested in david foster
wallace again somebody who i think is
going to be
pretty much ignored a hundred years from
now whereas
uh
you know ursula k le guin and philip k
dick will be read hundreds of years from
now
um
i'm not going to waste the time to read
infinite just when i have so many other
great things i can be reading
it seems to me that most of the people
that
i run into who are big on it tend to be
they're not very interested in other
things that i find interesting
i've read a few essays by david foster
wallace enough to be like
i don't get what the hype is about you
know um
and you know that's
that's basically all i have to do
you know i'm going to say something here
to the to the rest of you
you don't have to feel like you have to
read anybody just because other people
are into them you know it's your life
it's your brain it's your it's your time
i mean obviously if you're assigned to
work in class you know you should read
that because you're part of that class
right or you join a reading group you
should read the book that you're you're
reading but
just because somebody has some temporary
prestige
doesn't mean that we need to
go read them
i mean if they last a long time we might
say oh you know people are still into
this years and years later i should go
maybe i'll go back and check it out like
you know
i recently uh you know read uh virginia
woolf a room of her own and i'm like man
that's
pretty good stuff i can kind of see
where people are getting into her from
you know
um
so
yeah
you get to decide what you want to to
read
um dan did you ever deal with feelings
of doubt in your abilities as a
philosopher oh yeah i mean
all of us do all of us do except for nut
jobs who think that they're like god's
gift to the world right
um
there's a lot of things that you can go
through you know i i've mentioned a
couple times here that you can't read
everything right so
you can you can walk into a good
research library you know and you like
for example when i was at southern
illinois university we had an amazing
research library uh surprisingly good
but that was that was a product of
delete morris and his university
building that went on
and you know when i go to the marquette
rainer library it's
it's good it's not great but there's
still you you walk down a hall full of
books on you know the history of
philosophy or literature and you're like
oh man i'm never going to read all this
crap and even if i do i'm not gonna
remember three quarters of what i read
oh what am i gonna do you know
and that can you know it can make you
feel bad about yourself and your
prospects and all of that
but it doesn't have to
you know
um and you can also think about
you can you can easily subcumb to the
the uh stratified prestige system oh
that guy's from harvard he must be smart
no there's a bunch of dummies at harvard
just like there are everywhere else
right
some people are only there because they
kiss the right asses or because they
knew the right people or because it was
convenient for others that they be there
right
the the proportion between like great
thinkers and duds and you know
people in between is pretty much the
same anywhere you go but you know you
look at um how things work in the
profession and that could kind of get
you down right it could make you feel
bad because maybe your work won't get
published because you don't have some
you know big name person pushing it to
the academic press then again you want
to publish a work hell you can do it on
amazon these days right so there's lots
of ways of dealing with
with um these things and i guess you
could say the thing to do
is to
talk to other people right get get other
people's perspectives
and to
think it through
you know question your assumptions oh
i'll never get published how do you know
that
you know
research what it takes to get published
you know um there's lots of ways we can
we can approach these
these matters so
um
you know and and the other thing to keep
in mind
is
philosophy is difficult right
so
you can't like
be an expert in everything
if you are devoting your time to
understanding aristotle maybe that
requires the rest of your life and
that's okay because that's worthwhile
you know
if that means that you don't understand
nietzsche
how's that damaging the world or you or
anything like that people won't
necessarily expect you to
to study um
and talk about nietzsche right i mean so
long as you can like when you're
teaching undergrads expose them
competently to some ideas right not get
niche like completely wrong in the
classroom
you probably are doing good work you
know you're opening up minds you never
know too
what it's actually going to
to um
[Music]
bear fruit in right
students will contact you 10 years down
the line and be like oh you know
remember that me i didn't talk in class
i got something out of your class right
so
all right nl some say to lose is auntie
hegelian regard reading g-jack's more
theoretical work i find to lose and gjx
hegel quite alike can we deal with
differences in hegelian as a signifier
historically because i don't know what
the last part means there but i mean
again super high level of generality
that probably doesn't mean an awful lot
of stuff i mean deluse is explicitly
anti hegelia and he says he's anti
hegelian uh one of the best places to
see that is in his nietzsche book right
um which is a great book by the way i i
actually like it quite a bit
um
g-check and to lose if you're seeing
like
you know the two of them coming together
you're probably misreading both of them
because there's there's a lot of
differences
between them and you could you could you
know compare them against each other um
and it would be weird to find two big
thinkers like coinciding
anyway but you got to ask yourself well
what does auntie hegelian mean what is
being rejected
coming from hegel because you know you
could call me an auntie hegelian because
i think that you know history did not
end with the end of this book
right
so
um that's anti-hegelian isn't it end of
history didn't happen in 1807 or you
know whatever whatever other arbitrary
date we want to pick
um
i think that that hegel's
uh self-imposed demand that the system
be finished by the time
that he starts writing about it as an
epistemological requirement is is you
know
he doesn't have to do that
it's kind of irrational for him to do
that am i an anti hegelian because of
that you know it really depends sort of
like the thing i made
the remark i made earlier when it comes
to these these big level high level
abstractions
we got to be really pragmatic about it
we've got to say what does this actually
mean
to us otherwise we're just kind of
playing around with words
and you know that can be fun but it's
not getting us anywhere
um
ridicule currently on my first read of
aristotle's politics what in the world
is he talking about when he says
gymnastic exercises are a matter which
oligarchies deceive the people i don't
know i don't that doesn't come to mind
for me right right off the bat and i
wouldn't worry too much about it
gymnastic exercises encompasses
everything that has to do with the body
maybe what he's saying there is it's a
way for the oligarchs to keep the people
busy so that they're not paying
attention to development of their mind
um
i mean that could actually if we look at
it that this way we could think about
the fitness industry here in the united
states and um
the supplement industry and all of that
kind of stuff you know i'm reminded of
the one time that i did listen to the
alex jones show
uh as i was driving you know in the
countryside back from an engagement i
was like well i should check this out
and see what it is and i was amazed like
just how much of the show was devoted to
him hawking his supplements and i was
like
who's so stupid as to buy this crap well
his listeners right
not quite exactly the same thing as
as uh
oligarchy right but
kind of along the same line
uh sensor to none do you think
kierkegaard and nietzsche are similar in
more ways than being just existentialist
philosophers yeah i mean they can't be
similar they can't be existentialist
philosophers if they're not similar in
other ways than just being called
existentialist philosophers
uh i mean both of them are you know
reacting against the modes of thought of
their time and stressing the importance
of the individual
and you know the importance of affects
and we could go down the line about it
right and there's also some important
differences
and by the way uh people were already
noting that in hegel's time if you
google georg brandes who is a important
uh danish writer
he noted that the similarities not just
between kierkegaard and nietzsche but
also dostoyevsky and nietzsche and
suggested that nietzsche read both of
them
which nietzsche did with dostoyevsky
calling him a great psychologist
and didn't apparently do with with
kierkegaard but you know people were
already noting the similarities at the
time
somebody else who i would say
is connecting the dots miguel de una
muno uh later on lev chest off uh of
course carl josper's early on in the
20th century you know there's there's a
lot of uh points of confluence that's
part of why we can actually talk about
an existentialist movement in in
philosophy
um
bill says a friend of mine currently
studies philosophy i'm looking in
looking to get into it he gave me
descartes meditations and some plato are
these good for an introduction also what
is clean room philosophy i i don't know
what cleanroom philosophy refers to off
the top of my head but i'll just say
this there's like millions of terms out
there that you can find where somebody's
labeled some philosophy thing that's a
fad at the time
something that that was worth doing
descartes is definitely worth reading
plato is definitely worth reading
expect to re-read and re-read and reread
don't don't expect to get it all right
off the bat
[Music]
as a matter of fact you can say that
about any great philosopher and you can
also say that by the way about great
literature right don't expect to get it
all the first time around
and i i often start people off with
plato i don't know i would start him off
with descartes
um i usually bring him him in later but
i've seen people do that for their intro
to philosophy classes
you know it doesn't seem that productive
to me but um i guess you could do that
you know
so
kyle what did nietzsche get right
well i mean i think he's right about the
workings of rosontomont in part
mock shaler has a really great book sort
of taking nietzsche's ideas
criticizing them where they need
criticizing and then going further with
the resonte mont idea
i think a lot of people are driven by by
risantomon frankly
um
you know back back in let's say 2000 i
would say there's probably more people
that were on the left that were driven
by risotto now i would say most of the
right is like
clearly caught up within resonte mont uh
nietzsche would you know have nothing to
do with those people
um
you know the idea of the will to power
and the self as being
considerably more fictional and
fragmented than we we give it um
credit for being i think those are
those are certainly interesting ideas
that strike me as being pretty plausible
you know um
i think there's a lot of his ideas that
are useful in part more for what they're
criticizing than for what they're
they're advancing
so
mutant how do you read books do you ask
yourself many questions or you just try
to read through it as fast as possible
you should never ever try to read
through a book as fast as possible as a
matter of fact this whole idea of speed
reading
i think is if you're going to do
philosophy just put that out of your
mind you don't master philosophical
works you get exposed to them and you
get to know them just like you would a
person you don't master people right
uh and put them in your pocket and
you're like oh i've done joe and i don't
have to talk with him anymore
put all that speed reading [ __ ] to
the side and anybody who's like
competing with you about how many books
they've mastered or read
ignore them right
um i uh i just read books
i i don't have useful advice for people
uh unless i like sit down and really
think about okay what what are the
things you got to watch out for in this
this is like in those self-guided uh or
self-directed uh study videos um
i've been reading since i was three
years old
so
it's it's sort of like asking a fish how
do you swim
um i don't do a lot of taking notes or
underlining i never have in my life you
know
i did a bit of that in graduate school
never really got into that occasionally
if i think something is really important
i'll like maybe
dog ear a page
you know um
but different people read different ways
you don't have to feel like you should
read in a particular way other than like
you know respecting the book you know uh
saying this is gonna be some some work
and i need to be open to it and and
continually work on it right
uh
yorick um
what do you make of the counter argument
against nietzsche that people can't
create their own values it depends on
what you mean by create your own values
again we got to be clear we got to
clarify what we mean people create their
own values all the time
unless maybe you mean that they can't
create something that nobody else has
ever created in the history of mankind
yeah sure that's that's true trivially
true
um but people do create their own values
people select between ranges of values
people prioritize so
i don't see that as as
a real objection
uh
python what is your all-time favorite
band so if you asked me
30
years ago or maybe even longer i would
have said iron maiden um i don't have a
favorite band i have sort of a
constellation of
great bands that i love some of whom are
metal some of whom aren't
and
um
[Music]
you know they kind of
shift position every once in a while
many of them are metal so
dio motorhead
um black sabbath in its many iterations
judas priests rat
you know those those are a tank those
are
among my favorite bands um saxon raven
you know girl school
um rock goddess i i really like them as
well
but there's other bands in there as well
like that might surprise you like duran
duran i'm a huge duran duran fan
or new model army you know or our
local
violent femmes um or you know like i
mentioned earlier pj harvey i really
like her stuff
so i don't really have a favorite you
know
butter dog best way to read count there
is no best way to read count there's no
best way to read anybody
it really depends on what you're trying
to read and what you're doing
with it
uh
phillip what's your opinion about uh
lev warsaw philosophy school
don't know it so there's nothing i can
say about it
peter
says can anything be a form for example
is something as recently made up and
stupid as nft is a form is there a form
of nft depends on what you mean by form
plato's forms aristotle's forms other
kinds of forms right there isn't a
single conception of form
and you will find already in the
parmenides that socrates who's talking
with parmenides says that there isn't a
form for any kind of thing there isn't a
form for mud for example so
it's kind of a non-starter
[Music]
all right
just skipped a little bit here let me
scroll back up so i can get to where
okay chris any thoughts on victor frankl
and his book man's search for meaning
his concept of logotherapy
he seems to have been writing in the
existentialism field he's in
existentialism very solidly he has uh
another book that's better
more interesting about uh i think it's
called psychotherapy and existentialism
um i mean man's search for meaning
it's okay he was really surprised as he
writes in his other books that that one
took off so much because it's kind of
it's it's franco light right his other
books are more serious uh more rigorous
there's more to get out of it um you
know he he's doing an interesting form
of psychotherapy that is
certainly informed by his experiences
and by existentialism and by you know
thinking things out in in the
traditional
big tent freudian camp and doing other
things as well
um
[Music]
i enjoy reading viktor frankl you know
um i think that that some people who get
into viktor frankl are a little bit too
exclusively into viktor frankl
i think he's somebody who's better read
along with other people right but you
know there's there's people who are
interested in that
mf speaking of mcintyre what book of his
should i re start reading first and what
philosophers do i need to read or reread
before um
i mean
why do it before why not read in
conjunction after virtue probably is the
place to start because
that's the beginning of a four book
series that you can certainly get a lot
out of and nothing will stop you from
actually as you're reading his
discussion of plato going back and
reading the text that he's talking about
um
so you know after virtue and then
there's who's justice which rationality
and then three rival versions of moral
inquiry and then dependent rational
animals that's going to keep you busy
for a while i mean there's earlier books
like against the self images of the age
which is really awesome and you know
he's got a lot of there's a great book
that he's got called the unconscious
that came out of a class that he was
teaching way way back in the day
but you know you can you can jump in
basically wherever you want to you know
so
all right um
[Music]
bill do you think hume's problem of
induction and his odd problem can be
solved
well there is no problem of induction in
hume because he doesn't call it that and
there is no
is ought problem in him because he
doesn't call it that that's what
scholars later on reconstituted as you
should read hume right the answers are
there in hume
um and the is odd thing if you actually
like read the text you're going to find
that what the point that hume is making
is not that we we can never derive an is
from an auth oh don't ever do that sort
of thing
it's just that we all we have a whole
bunch of odds in our in our background
that we're thinking of all the time
that's it's a much more trivial point
than a lot of people have made of it and
hume effectively deals with the problem
of induction you know this this big
thing you know
read the inquiry i mean by the time you
get to the end of it
you know hume's making sweeping claims
like you know human nature is basically
the same across time that's why we can
actually know reliably that the person
is not going to get out of jail
there's a lot of nonsense and silliness
that has been made by people in the
history of philosophy and in writing
introductory textbooks
about um what exactly hume is saying so
i would actually go to the hymn
um
richard santos thoughts on joseph peeper
jacques mariten and peter kreef the only
one of those that i've given any real
thought to is uh jacques mariten
i think that martin can be interesting
but also kind of a misses the point and
then then goes off to the proverbial
races
um i i think that you know
mauritan is
you know an interesting guy but he's
he's kind of second rate
um i don't think he uh he knows the
history of philosophy all that well and
i think that you know he criticized
maurice blondell
on behalf of 18 jill stone without
knowing what the hell he was talking
about
and that's that's usually a bad sign
i don't read peeper i don't read criefed
so
i mean i read some of them back in the
day but not enough to actually say
anything interesting about them
josh what do you think about viewing
biblical hermeneutics through a
psychoanalytic lens which psychoanalytic
lens psychoanal psychoanalysis can mean
anything you like from crazy reikians
you know doing weird wacky stuff about
the orgone and sexual energy all the way
over to you know uh lacan and what he's
doing and contemporary psychoanalysis
some of which is informed by you know
lacan or young or adler or hornay you
you gotta you gotta clarify
what psychoanalytic lens you mean when
when you say that sort of thing
um
cole i've been reading a lot of
heidegger this past week and found it
surprisingly manageable due to his
reputation
for being difficult to read i still
can't understand nietzsche tricks or
tips i i don't know i don't understand
or know what you don't understand about
nietzsche
or what nature works you're reading so i
don't have any tips or tricks about that
we'd have to get more specific
um
raja how can a student find out what
they like in their academic journey
whether sociology philosophy political
science to pursue
how to know if academics is even
something one should do okay so
um
read stuff in the literature
uh maybe take a class here there
talk to
people who are in those majors and see
whether that's the kind of thing that
you're interested in
now whether you should
go into academics well that's you know
that's that's a it's not as if you
automatically should do that unless you
have a lot of disposable income and
don't you're not particularly concerned
about what you're going to do later on
and if that's the case more power to you
i've known some people like that
i don't come from that kind of
background and most the people that i
know don't that's not the case
if your if your goal is to become a
university professor
this is not a particularly great time to
try to do that
it is possible to get a job
you got to beat out you know
anywhere from 150 to 900 other
applicants to get that job
which means you also have to go to
graduate school and stuff like that if
your goal is to study and then apply it
in some way
you know people in philosophy in
political science in sociology go into a
variety of other fields right
when i was an undergraduate systems
analysis was a big thing for philosophy
people
and um
you know now there's other things right
but you have to kind of be savvy you
can't just like go through the process
do your major
course of study and then be like all
right where's my job you gotta you gotta
like you know plan your future a bit so
i would say that's you know
something that you should give some
thought to and again talk to other
people um
you know they they can give you an idea
about what you might do
tongue uh
is there a difference between the term
time and the term temporal temporality
and heidegger's philosophy well yes one
is zeit and one is zeitly kite
temporality is you could say the aspects
of time right
so you know heidegger will talk about
the temporality of the future
in being in time for example he talks
about four aqua primordials
and you know these are uh
pre-understanding mood or attunement
throneness
and uh language or or discourse
in german and each of these has its own
temporality right mood is it is
attunement to the past right by the time
that we're feeling a mood we're already
like rooted in the past
pre-understanding oriented towards the
future that's coming towards us right
language runs and articulates through
all of it throneness the presence these
are temporalities
you could also call them times if you
want to
going all the way back to ancient
philosophy where they're they're called
you know seneca talks about the three
times
um future present past augustine does as
well
so
i mean don't think don't try to think of
them time and temporality as being
things that are separable from each
other but think of when we're attending
to temporality we're attending to how we
are in time you know
um
[Music]
all right let's see here
gabriel where can i find
material about seneca on hardships i
only found something in the letters to
achilles it depends on what you mean by
hardships
um i mean all of the major treatises and
the consolations are talking about
things we could call hardships the
consolations are written because
somebody died and people feel like crap
because of it
so is death the hardship the death of a
loved one i mean
i guess you could look at the
consolations
um
you know even things like on benefits
include helping a friend out
when they're facing
hardships we could say so i i don't
think that
uh
it's not a topic that that that doesn't
come up over and over again but it
depends on what you mean by hardships
right
so
all right it looks like i'm starting to
get like uh
some people with with quite a few
questions i'm going to try to pick
people we haven't
already um
done before
or answered a question from
um thomas how do you think philosophy of
education applying conscientiation
that seems like a made-up term
of whiteness in light of white
supremacists subtler colonialism is a
means for humanization if at all with
regard to existentiality this is a lot
of this is almost like word salad at
this point there's let's see if we can
zone in on one question
philosophy of education
applying let's say the concept of
whiteness in light of white supremacist
settler colonialism
as a means for humanization so yeah i
mean uh
what you know what what people throw out
there as settler and by the way settler
colonialism can can be
tied in with all sorts of conceptions of
races it can be
uh you know effort you know african
americans going back to liberia and
setting up their own caste system
but colonialism you know there's uh
there's aspects that we want to be kind
of careful in applying these things so
we're not just like you know painting
with too broad a brush but you can say
that you know one of the key aspects of
colonialism read franz fanon you know
for example black skin white masks he's
got some great phenomenological analyses
is treating other people who are human
as if they're not human or as if they're
subhuman
honor rent by the way also talks about
this in in the
origins of totalitarianism because the
first part is devoted to colonialism
right
um so you know no no vast surprise here
um
white supremacy you know i mean to begin
with white supremacy is just a silly
thing to begin with
i'm not i'm not trivializing it
they do a lot of damage they do a lot of
harm both to themselves and even more to
other people
but this whole concept of like white
supremacy you see this in questions all
the time um
about uh various races and and you know
people are always answering these
questions saying you stupid americans um
always want to view things in terms of
white versus something else and this
doesn't actually fit into it you know
for example ancient greece and rome are
not white right because that category
isn't even around one way you can tell
that that that doesn't matter in terms
of skin color being important one of the
examples that the stoics give of
something that's purely indifferent that
doesn't matter at all
color of one's skin black or white
right so
you know
white supremacy people thinking that
whiteness is something you know
fundamentally good and they're in caught
up in this manichaean struggle between
themselves and pick whoever else you
like
it's dehumanizing and it's also
dehumanizing as martin luther king
pointed out for the racist themself
right so i mean we can we can certainly
um it doesn't have to be philosophy of
education it could be you know uh
i mentioned in the world views and
values class which is an intro class we
look at um the letter from a birmingham
jail you know we can do this in all
sorts of ways um
why don't you know what is standing in
the way of
being more human
um i mean there can be other things
where
differences matter
um
you know but
seems to me it's kind of a weird hill
that a lot of people on on a lot of
sides want to uh fight on
all right uh mf also the genocide of
native americans nobody talks about
who the hell is the nobody there i've
been hearing about it since i was a
little kid i mean it's widely
acknowledged you know it's part of a lot
of curriculums people got to avoid these
sweeping hyperbolic statements they do
zero good uh for for any sort of real
thinking about these matters
um oh now here's an interesting question
could i do an ama with evil saddler
and i would say in theory yes but i
would have to find some way
to as i'm streaming
reverse the the colors right
and youtube doesn't have stuff like that
in the native um streaming app that i'm
using right here and i'd want to do a
voice modifier as well
so it's it's
possible
but i would have to
find some way to put it through um
filters to make it work
um
and i don't actually have the tech know
how to do that at this point in time so
but it is kind of a cool idea
uh richard aguirre do you think
utilitarianism is compatible with
christianity depends on which
christianity you're talking about i mean
you're talking about a
vast tradition
uh going back to millennia
and uh you know which which one do you
mean um which idea do you mean and which
utilitarianism do you mean you know if
we're gonna do these sort of like can
this mix with this
um
you gotta you gotta like be more
specific
what about what you have in mind i will
say this that mill
thinks of utilitarianism as bringing
together
some key insights from christianity and
interestingly enough from stoicism he
tells you this right there
in on liberty right
or is it in uh is it in his
utilitarianism i might be mixing up the
passages in which this this happens
um
all right i can't read cyrillic stuff so
i'm not sure what what the name here is
can you tell me which tradition even
though i know analytical versus
continental does not apply anymore is
mostly present in the us i know that
some unis in the uk still do value their
analytical tradition analytic philosophy
is the dominant form of philosophy
uh here in the united states and you
know
continental philosophy both of them are
sets of traditions and neither one is a
single tradition right
um and we're not entirely past it
um so they're both they're both there
right james what do you think of wd
ross's primo fascia duties i like them
so much that i teach them every time i
teach ethics because i think it's a
useful approach for people to think
about
i like wd ross
uh paul litter do you have any
recommendations or good quality news
sources are there good philosophical
works that can help increase media
literacy
that's a good question i mean i don't i
i'm sure there's some newer
philosophical works that would help with
that but i'm not reading them because i
spend most of my time reading stuff in
the history of philosophy
and there's lots of good philosophical
works that can help you to increase
media literacy but not in
a direct way right so
i would say
that's that's good good quality news
sources yeah i mean read read widely
right
um
stay away from like cable tv and stuff
like that unfortunately a lot of
newspapers these days are owned by big
conglomerates
so they're not particularly good but
look for local sources like here in
milwaukee
the best news sources urban milwaukee is
one of them better than the journal
sentinel our official paper of record
and actually the kenosha news is better
than our journal sentinel because our
local newspaper has become so garbage
because it's owned by one of these big
you know publishing consortiums um it's
really too bad because both there there
was originally two papers here in
milwaukee the milwaukee journal which
leaned left the milwaukee sentinel which
re leaned right they both won pulitzers
and stuff like that then they merged in
the 1990s and became one big newspaper
and they were still doing good work but
years and years of erosion have really
done them in and this is the case in in
many
many cities uh here in the us i mean
it's good also i mean if you're an
american try to get plenty of uh
international news
and not just through
you know the international section in
the new york times or the washington
post i mean
read read papers or read news sites that
are actually coming out from
uh
people in other countries and see what
they they have to say right
um so that and then you know what you're
doing is you're trying to create
composite pictures rather than be like i
this is my one reliable
news source
[Music]
this is made of clay does new
materialism really move away from
subject-oriented ontology i don't see
how it could do that
i don't know i don't know enough about
the new materialism to say
uh jerome can you explain kant's
categorical imperative formula of
autonomy well you know this is what we
mean by the second formulation of the
categorical imperative
um act always so as to treat humanity
not autonomy humanity in yourself and
others
as a means as an ends never just as a
mere mean so you're supposed to respect
the autonomy of other people you're not
supposed to just instrumentalize them
um and you should also do the same with
yourself so for example kant has an
argument why you shouldn't prostitute
yourself you know
uh as an example
um we're getting close to the the end
time and i do have an event at the top
of the hour so i got to get myself some
lunch before that
um i'm gonna just take whatever i can
um
[Music]
silly will you cover more of martin
heidegger's work aside from your core
concepts you currently have on your
channel
um no i'm gonna keep doing more core
concepts about heidegger why why should
i
um
not use that that formula
um
let's see here
a lot a lot of questions down here
um
danny did you hear about oliva
blanchette passing away i certainly did
you know great loss um
somebody who i've corresponded with over
the years great blondel scholar
um
temec are you aware of some foreign
youtubers steal your videos literally
copy your videos and just translate
their language
no i rely on on youtube to like catch uh
those sorts of things if they're
actually doing the work to translate me
talking into a different language should
i do the work to try to track them down
i'm a pretty busy guy
um
d i'm halfway through senators seneca's
letters on ethics he's quickly become my
favorite of the stoics i'd like to learn
more about him in his world is there a
good source i should check out well you
can read more of seneca's works you
mentioned the university of chicago
translation each of those has a nice
introduction by the translators
um you know learning about his world is
um you know important part reading other
people or who are from his world like
for example epictetus or musonius rufus
right
[Music]
let's see
oh yeah okay so here's a good question
online person
anything that heidegger anything you
think that heidegger got interestingly
wrong
yeah i mean i think heidegger one of the
big mistakes he makes is even though he
talks about like tradition and community
and stuff like that
he's got this
point of view that he expresses in being
in time where any sort of
approach to fundamental ontology
that is involving an ethical perspective
or a religious perspective is already
like
stopping the inquiry at the start and
you you know you could compare and
contrast his work to that of say mock
shaler
who's who's explicitly doing a
phenomenology of values
um
and i think uh heidegger is wrong on
that and and uh shaler's right and you
know i'm i'm only one of many who's
recognized that
adrian pepperzak the great
um dutch phenomenologist who taught at
loyola here just to the south of us in
chicago
for decades um has brought this up as
well about about heidegger i also think
that heidegger
and again pepper zach has pointed this
out and talked about this i think that
heidegger is wrong to think that uh
anxiety or ox is the fundamentally
disclosed mood i think that perhaps aw
or wonder could be i think maybe love
could be as well and again shaler you
know
sees this too
as well
um
yolao asks are you single no i've been
married for 10 years you know anybody
who follows me on social media sees me
with my spouse andy schacha
i reference her pretty frequently
because we are
you know very close so
uh
that's that's an easy one to address um
what else can we
hit on
quickly
um
oh here's a good one from the
unnoticeable any philosophical novels or
stories you'd recommend i mean that
could be an entire session
last semester
you've probably seen some of the videos
coming out from this last semester i
taught an entire class
on ursula k le guin's earthsea
novels and short stories
um and so she's definitely somebody who
i think is is massively
important also her classmate philip k
dick
who i'm hoping to teach a class on this
coming fall from milwaukee institute of
art and design very philosophically
informed as well as theologically and
psychologically
there's lots and lots and lots of
thinkers who explicitly
talk about philosophy within
their their literary work dostoevsky who
we talked about earlier has characters
who like make extensive philosophical
arguments uh miguel de una muno does as
well somebody who we brought up earlier
um
franz kafka has has uh people doing that
in his his books as well
um
but there's lots of uh of literary
figures who are influenced
considerably by philosophy sometimes in
a more subterranean way sometimes in a
much more
explicit way so
there's you know you could take a look
at my um
worlds of speculative fiction series
which
you know has got a lot of entries in it
you can check look at the playlist and
then look at the authors and many of
them are people who are bringing
philosophy up whether whether it's like
roger zelazny and sort of neoplatonism
in the amber thing or recently talked
about philip pullman
and his dark materials stuff where
there's lots of philosophical concepts
being brought up so i think i think
there's great room for for that sort of
thing
um
all right so we got about another minute
who else can i take that i can answer
very
quickly
okay so eric said has an interesting
question here about wittgenstein which
one of my clients was asking me about
earlier uh this week do you think that
the later wittgenstein was correct in
his philosophy of language
kind of correct i think that he's
certainly better off than where he was
in the tractatus
which is by even by wittgenstein's own
admission like completely off base
except for certain kinds of language and
i think that had wittgenstein actually
read much more widely he would have been
a vastly better philosopher and he would
have generated a vastly more adequate
philosophy of language
i actually you know tried to write my my
master's thesis on wittgenstein with a
major wittgenstein scholar and couldn't
get her to understand why i was so
interested in the notion of language
games as being something that could be
figured within language games and how
that could work and you know
i think part of the problem was just the
conceptual apparatus was not adequate
wittgenstein was living in a century in
which people were like incredibly
interested in language and an entire
revolution took place within semiotics
that he was totally uh you know unaware
of as far as we can tell
so
you know
there's there's some cool stuff in there
and you know like uh philosophical
investigations or remarks on the
foundations of mathematics the blue and
brown books uh uncertainty you know just
to name a few
of the things you might go to
but
it's always
you know you see him doing a lot of work
to arrive at a few
solid insights and he could have done so
much more so that's a good place to to
end i think
um
and i'll see all of you in some of the
other online events we got coming up
this month heavy metal class
um we're talking about parody and metal
[Music]
we're doing uh the
parable
of the talents and parable of the sower
by
octavia butler for the worlds of
speculative fiction we've got a bunch of
other things going on as well so
all right thanks everybody um
good time here and i'm gonna get some
lunch hope all of you are doing well
wherever you're located you know so good
night to some of you good morning to
some of you good afternoon to some of
you
and i'll catch you somewhere else in
the
ether